i remember it so vividly i wasn't
watching but i was listening on the
radio because i was going to the
arkansas derby flew into memphis drove
the arkansas derby the cubs were playing
friday afternoon best time slot in in
the entire world in sports uh and they
had mike glennon throwing out the first
pitch and he did the in-game interview
and they're like what does it feel like
to be qb one and then they drafted mitch
whiskey so the com sorry the bears at
least are learning
that don't trot out your quarterback
until after the draft because then you
can trot out the correct one and not say
hey we have andy dalton at wrigley today
everyone please clap
and there are so many parallels between
what happened four years ago glennon
comes in free agency gets the contract
that implies he is qb1
then the drafting of the quarterback
happens four years ago was trubisky this
year obviously it was justin fields but
there still is
the persistent sense like there was in
2017 when john fox was the coach that
the veteran is gonna be the week one
starter
no matter what and and look i i i'm told
that dalton was told when he signed
you're the guy week one
and i don't know how they walk that back
especially if fields ends up being
pretty damn good and the locker room's
like we got to go with this guy i guess
at a certain point you just have to say
to andy dalton sorry man i mean here's
the film i we can't we're trying to win
football games here if it fields is that
good but dalton's under the impression
he's the guy week one because he was
told he's the guy week one when he
signed the one-year deal with the bears
and that's the part i do not understand
mike i think i am not going to sit here
and tell you that justin fields should
be the week one starter because i don't
know i'm not watching the practice i'm
not a football coach what i do know
though is
if you're smart and you run a smart
organization and you're smart coach
you leave it up to competition that is
the best football coaches will always
say
you know it's a competition we want our
best guys out there so i don't know why
matt niggy came out this week and said
well there's nothing i could see that
could happen that wouldn't have annie
dalton being the week one starter
how what what are you talking about what
if justin fields is the greatest
quarterback you've ever seen you're
really not going to start them it just
that's such a
boxed in thinking that i i it drives me
insane because a good coach and i know
you know he could say one thing do
another but i think he actually believes
it i think he's saying this is the right
thing to do have any all no the right
thing to do is put out the best player
and if it's justin fields
that should be the guy who starts week
one and i'm not saying that you should
hurry up his pr you know his timeline
i'm not saying if it's if it's even that
you start justin field no no if justin
fields is that much better than annie
dalton let's just say it he should start
that's just what a winning organization
does not trot out and say well andy
alton's a week one starter no matter
what
i've got some thoughts on that i will
hold them until after we hear a little
bit from matt nagy talking about this
very situation as it relates to
whoever the starting quarterback will be
week one sunday night football on nbc
when the bears play the rams here's
maggie
i'll give you updates as we go as to how
the guys are doing but as far as the
depth chart goes this is where we're at
with andy as the one
with with justin as the two with nick as
a three but all three of those guys know
that you need to produce you need to
play well you need to compete you need
to be the best quarterback you can be
and then it's going to be really pretty
easy for us to be able to see who that
is and how that goes and then there'll
be a process and a plan
we're going to stick to that it's not
going to change tomorrow that plan is
not going to change tomorrow the plan is
not going to change in training camp the
plan is a is a is a plan and it's been
thought out
and so as we go um i'm just taking some
time on this question because i think
you know this could go every day and i
just want you to know that that's kind
of as we go here where i'm at you know
and so um
depth chart wise yep but to go back to
your original question hub
if that was the case yes then um
uh justin would be our starter
[Music]
you know they said back in 2012 pete
carroll was so brave to start russell
wilson as a rookie over matt flynn the
guy they gave the eight-figure signing
bonus to and and it wasn't it would have
been brave to not start russell wasn't
because everybody in the building knew
that wilson was clearly superior that's
the point that you're getting at if
there's one guy who emerges the best guy
whoever it is he needs to be the
quarterback but here's what i think matt
neggie is doing
mettnagi is incorporating
into
this quarterback situation the same
approach andy reid used four years ago
with patrick mahomes and alex smith
because you know what if they had had a
full and fair and open competition in
2017
maybe my homes would have won it as a
rookie maybe
i had travis kelsey on this program
during the 2017 season and the issue
came up with my homes at practice and
kelsey said this guy is doing amazing
things reed's force of personality i
think was able
to hold the locker room together behind
alex smith for that one year but but
that was the deliberate plan
one year
alex smith plays we get my homes ready
and i feel like nagi's trying to do that
same thing and i think it's apples and
oranges but i think that's what he's
trying to do
no offense to andy dalton
had him on our show very nice guy
actually i'm going to give him a ton of
credit because everything i've read he
has been exactly what you'd ex you'd
hope from a veteran quarterback in terms
of uh you know rookie quarterback coming
in
and him helping him and him not saying
i'm threatened by him
he's helped justin fields alex smith was
better than andy dalton and that thing
was going you know what i mean like so
it doesn't com it doesn't apply because
what they what they win 10 games a year
before and went to the playoffs like
you you could say oh yeah the bears went
to the playoffs this year
they invented a seventh seed just so the
bears could lose on nickelodeon okay
they didn't go to the playoffs i don't
want to hear it i really don't
they weren't like good they weren't good
that wasn't this isn't a cohesive thing
that's going forward they're trying to
put it back together and they're trying
to do it from the quarterback position
because everything else was ready to go
you know what i mean this defense is not
getting younger the like this is the
window is they're in a weird spot right
now where
the you know that we we've talked about
it a million times that the plan going
forward for most franchises especially
when they're looking at quarterback is
find that young quarterback on a rookie
deal
build up your roster around him in those
first four five years that's when you
have to win
so what are we doing here like the
defense is ready to go and again this is
all just saying justin fields is doing
great and he's way better than andy
dalton but if those things are true like
what are we doing here that it's a
wasted year in my opinion of a defense
that is not getting younger
yeah chiefs were 12 and 4 the year
before they drafted patrick mahomes they
had to spring from 27 up to 10 to get
him
and and it was easier to justify sitting
him it was alex smith had equity years
of equity playoff appearances built up
with the kansas city chiefs but there
was a general understanding that they
had gotten as far as an organization as
they could possibly go and this is a
franchise that had been trying for
almost 50 years to get back to the super
bowl they had had good seasons that
never quite ended the way they wanted to
they had so many home playoff losses i
think it was the perfect time for them
to do what they did
but again that's what makes it apples
and oranges this is a different
situation andy dalton has no equity with
the bears this is a team that is
desperately groping in the dark for a
franchise quarterback
and you mean to tell me that you're
going to slow down the development of
the guy who may be the one
simply because you made a promise to
andy dalton in march that that to me is
where it all falls apart
and people love to point to the
patriarchal homes they love to point to
the aaron rodgers and i think for the
most part those are the exceptions not
the rules because those guys again if
andy dalton was 12-4 last year took the
bears to 12 and four in a play and won
the nfc north like i would be sitting
here right now being like yeah of course
you got to roll with annie dalton see if
it's still the magic is still there
that's that says it all alex smith was a
good quarterback he was 12 and four that
team was rolling they could take a
chance on a guy who coming into the
draft people were like hey texas tech
who knows and build him up and get him
to a spot where he's going but that's
the exception not the rule i think that
in today's nfl you see it a lot more
guys start right away because you want
to start that clock you want to get your
guy ready to go and have that window
where you have him cheaper than you will
have him if he becomes that big time
franchise quarterback then then takes up
tons of salary cap
let's hear from justin fields on his
development as a rookie and the extent
to which he expects to get some help
from the veteran andy dalton here's
fields
my job is strictly to get better uh be
the best quarterback i can be and
uh you know help my team win so that's
that's what i'm gonna do whether it's
starting whether it's you know sitting
um i'm gonna do whatever
uh
that's that's going to help us win so
yeah if i've learned
a lot of things i i couldn't even name
off a few things but i mean he's talked
to me a lot uh i actually went to dinner
with him and his wife so we talked a lot
there and i'm kind of just his
background and stuff like that their
story but i mean andy and nick they've
been awesome i mean probably bigger than
you guys even even though um
just just yeah i mean andy's completely
taking me under his wing
any question that i have for him uh he's
he's gonna answer and then even when i'm
throwing i think there was one day out
uh after otas i was throwing extra after
packs and he stayed out there
specifically just to you know uh see
maybe what i was doing wrong and he was
just trying to help help me out so i
mean he's been a huge help for sure
that's good that's part of being a
teammate and that's the the tension
that's inherent to being the older guy
who knows he's not going to be there for
very long and the younger guy who's
trying to learn the ropes and when
you're in that interpersonal situation
it's kind of hard to be a jerk and just
kind of give the cold shoulder to the
rookie and be overly protective of the
job that you may not keep for very long
anyway so it's good that andy dalton is
doing what he's doing but i think that
would be the normal human thing to do
if you're trying to have some sort of
spirit of camaraderie in the
organization the question is how long
will it take to get justin fields to the
point where
he he is clearly the better option there
were some questions about justin fields
it was a surprise that the bears traded
from 20 to number 11 to get him sims
thought he'd linger all the way to the
bottom of the round you know sims has
concerns about that throwing motion and
it is a little clunky it is a little
funky he's got that elbow that gets
thrown out and it takes a little longer
than maybe it should to get the ball out
and sims had other concerns about justin
fields that the the notion that that
he's got epilepsy may have caused some
teams to view him differently uh just
because that's a health concern that
other quarterbacks don't have it's
unfortunate that that's the way it is
but that's the way it is they look at
the total package of who they're
drafting but uh you know i i
look
having him at number 11
puts an added degree of expectation and
pressure and intensity and urgency on
his development and even if they plan to
have andy dalton as the week one starter
bears fans
are they're gonna be going nuts
waiting for justin feels to get out
there and
you know ryan pace and matt nagy this is
this is that we talked about the uh you
know the the magic bullet in
with aaron rodgers and going to denver
this is it for them this is their magic
bullet they had to do this they have to
they have to have justified be good this
year
otherwise it's curtains on them because
you don't i mean it's almost
unprecedented at this point that ryan
pace gets to decide another quarterback
so they need
they need him to play and they need to
play well so everyone feels the pressure
don't you think though that when whoever
it was in the organization that
authorized the trade up to get justin
fields implicit in that is you can't
have ryan pace and matt nagy on the hot
seat this year you have to give fields
two years to show who he is what a mess
that would be though you fired gm in the
comments we hire new ones who don't want
justin fields mike you're talking about
the bears everything you just said would
be fine if the bears had any logic ted
phillips was probably like i don't care
just draft them they did they don't make
sense they don't run well there's i mean
the fact that ryan pace and matt nicky
got to decide the next quarterback is
stupid to begin with like that shouldn't
here's my here's my theory
you want my theory yeah my theory is ted
phillips ted phillips is on the hot seat
with them this time the 20-plus years
he's the common threat he's the guy
who's been hiring all these people i'm
telling you i think that because when it
happened 2019 season
when the train was starting to roll in
that direction phillips was attached to
it
i know we didn't touch them too it's a
fair question how long is a guy who has
yeah who doesn't have a football title
no get to hire football people before
he's accountable i mean his his
it's all coming to an end anyway because
when the mccaskey sell the team ted
phillips is gone so
you could you could spin it that way as
well
i just think that that phillips i think
phillips is on board with it because
phillips is out the door if they are and
i think phillips helped i don't know
this but this is just common sense i
think phillips helped engineer a
conversation with the mccaskeys that if
we do this and go get a quarterback we
got to give these guys two years minimum
to develop this guy
we'll see they're not they don't run
like a normal organization with with uh
coherent thoughts so nothing surprises
me they could
the bears could go
6 and 11 is at the news records now 6
and 11 justin fields can look like so so
and they might give matt nagy a 10-year
contract like who knows
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports